thank you Austin Texas it's good to be
here my name is Hans Kim I am a comedian
and this is a dating show how it works
is somebody gets the buckets from the
front table and puts them on the stage
preferably soon and then I pick up names
out of the bucket and then two people
randomly go on a date live on stage for
90 seconds what a concept
smashing two strangers together in
public we can all judge them and make
fun of them together this is a communal
activity this is church
give it up for dating
the concept
two people meeting
we don't have we only have one lgbtqia
plus please don't be homophobic switch
your sexual orientation tonight
we need to be inclusive you sir have you
ever thought about sucking dicks
oh [__] I already turned him that was
easy
go ahead and sign on up in the gay
bucket
okay then what the [__] was that thing
about you think about a lot of things
about not sucking dicks
look at me I don't suck dicks isn't that
funny
well
you know not all of us are going to be
progressives that you know love gays
some of us are going to be old
homophobes like this guy
uh my name is Hans Kim I am actually
uh good at dating these are not hickeys
on my neck this is actually just uh Jiu
Jitsu Marx just
the boys and I we were choking each
other a little bit
um but anyways this really isn't about
my STDs uh we got a great guest host
Tonight this guy is not only sexually
active right now but he is independently
wealthy from cryptocurrencies what a
nerd give it up for Paul ciphers a nerd
[Applause]
here he is
any uh World of Warcraft games going on
in your life
can we get his mic on I got it I figured
it out five years into comedy I know how
to turn on a microphone everybody
the Panic is still there when the mic
doesn't work
um but yes thank you for coming Paul
how's your girlfriend your long-term
girlfriend doing she's doing well she uh
she rented a coffee shop and threw her
own birthday party yesterday while I was
in Houston with several girls attended
so I went to like a room of a coffee
shop a room of girls yes
uh she met a bunch of girls on Bumble
BFF that was half of them that's what my
girlfriend's working with right now
uh she's dating apps to find friends
that's how social we are
I'm sure you're gonna have lots of
advice for a contestants tonight uh yeah
I think I'll I I've been looking at some
of the guys I think I can tell them a
few things and be like why don't you get
a girlfriend and then make her find her
own Social Circle outside of you make
her quit comedy and become a normal
person that's what you gotta do
Paul is very funny he has one joke about
drunk drivers yeah and he likes to hold
the mic
how I just love what they're doing out
there and I hope there's more of them
soon well hope well hopefully none of
them are here tonight uh we all want to
be responsible on the road and in in the
bedroom uh we got some names and buckets
here tonight are you guys ready to watch
people date
hell yeah let's pick out a woman
a straight female we got Sally B coming
up
Sally B
[Applause]
I am not revealing her last name because
this is going out live on the internet
the stairs are right over there to the
left go ahead and sit at the red table
uh yeah
sign up here there anywhere
so this is going out Live on YouTube
just FYI Sally B's uh I'm not gonna say
her last name
she got signed up you got signed up
against your wishes she seems incredibly
happy to be on stage
this is actually how most of my first
dates start with a woman showing up and
seeing me and being like great yeah with
a woman shouting I'm gonna [__] kill
you guys
this is a great start to a day this is
the dynamic that Paul and I are familiar
with go ahead and pick up that mic and
say into the tip of that microphone
just hold on dude just saying to the
table microphone who signed you up
against your wishes
people that I thought
well you're gonna find someone else new
to love most
her the one filming the show that's
being recorded right now
she's working for free
thank you so much for signing up your
friend
oh it's your birthday
well what better way to celebrate your
birthday than going on an awkward first
date
whoa I actually met a girl I first
stayed on my birthday a long time ago
and how'd that turn out ah not great
well hopefully Sally's gonna turn it
turn this dynasty around Sally how long
have you been single
two months
three months
what a loser
God that's not too bad
two months I kill myself I was single
for two months
anyways
what have you been doing for two months
just collecting cats
okay I have no idea what I'm doing for
two months
she's been drugged
she's a Nexium she's in a cult
so what are you looking for in a
heterosexual man
a man with a cough there's one over
there
with a
Coronavirus
um let's go let's start East Coast West
Coast dream man where would he be born
and raised
all right
she likes soft boys
so what is like a typical California
dude like a surfer like hey bro it's
good to see you on this date no
no
um I don't know how to answer this
question uh she's a human being let's go
let's go uh ripped or like heroin skinny
which one would you choose ripped over
okay ripped West Coast well you're not
gonna find any of those here that's not
we got fat Texas guys
real guys guys
well let's see what this bucket picks
we're gonna find a nice West Coast guy
for Sally B
Tyler Haskell
[Applause]
is he from your friend group do you know
Tyler I do know Tyler well let's watch
you guys awkwardly
interact in a sexual way
remember this is all about sex so don't
try to be professional
Tyler Haskell you guys are the only
people that signed up tonight
we're just gonna watch your he's not
looking for a staircase he's doing over
the top rope like Triple H
a parkour nerd and Sally beesla
going on a date for 90 seconds
pick up that mic and start talking to
each other like it's a date starting now
how's it going Tyler
thank you
laughs
what do we say to each other
I thought it was already on
well uh once again happy birthday last
night was fun yesterday it was fun yeah
yeah
party down six three that was the
hangover this morning a little rough
yeah a little rough
uh yeah lounged out most of the day
I think we barely made it out alive this
morning yeah like 2PM
uh uh yeah I think I like having a
conversation with Tyler now
um
yeah I think I slept in until like noon
yeah
um
but uh
see you guys uh I don't know what to say
in front of everybody
um
oh this is awkward this this is
something huh yeah
uh so got any travel plans coming up I
do yeah and
yeah nice for how long 10 days
sweet what are you gonna do no idea I
haven't planned it yet it's all me what
about you uh and time give it up for
Tyler and Sally
a real love on the Spectrum meets
Desperate Housewives
because you guys [__] last night what
happened
this is incredible
the chemistry is so awkward
there has to have been at least a hand
job or
uh that's what they all say you had a
group for a group orgy with your friends
okay that's how a lot of them start so
you went to Sixth Street do you hate
your friends
what did you do on Sixth Street I think
so
she went to Boston yeah she did
Tyler asked
for the bowl Tyler which is which is
your strong suit your length or your
girth
and if it's neither that's so okay okay
length I guess I mean could be below
it could be both
he's got the Pete Davidson
look going on calm on the surface but
below the belt he's [__] packing a
wall up
so yeah for a guy that can't turn on a
microphone I hope you know how to turn
on a lady
anyways
so why are you guys here what is this
what is the amalgamation of everybody
what is do we do we already go over this
I took Edibles right out here so I'm
gonna be asking questions twice a lot
tonight nobody knows yeah we just met
these people who are you guys what do
you guys all do together yeah
did you murder somebody
yeah you're definitely gentrifying
Austin
for the weekend it's your birthday yeah
okay and that's is that why so you came
for the week it was before your birthday
you came here oh okay damn money because
he told me let's go independently
wealthy crypto I'm actually
independently completely bankrupt from
crypto now I have zero dollars I eat
beans every day well you know when you
were rich on crypto you were Rich yeah
we can just focus on that part
obviously everyone's pouring out because
everyone knows it's a Ponzi scheme but
so
you're all friends Growing Up High
School how did you guys meet well
girls oh so you drag the guys along but
fun fun drag sorry all right that's
awesome we met through mutual friends
over the weekends oh so they're
absolutely these people had sex already
that's what happened do you pick two
people out of a record that had sex
already it's crazy what are the chances
Miracles can happen jeez yeah you people
are just like I already [__] yesterday
let me try to try it again
double or nothing
so uh uh Sally you're going to Bali that
makes a lot of sense you have resting
Bali face
that means you love the Finer Things in
life and you have disposable income
and you're destroying
indigenous black and brown neighborhoods
with your it's fine don't worry about it
well
performance having fun okay
we're here for 70 years you want a drink
you want to have fun in the cool places
I went to Houston over the weekend I'm
here it's awesome
what do you think Tyler would do in Bali
do you think he would have fun or do you
think he'd be you know just getting
burned all the time
he would be at the beach clubs
all weekend doing what the taxes for the
clubs
yeah I mean I would be uh definitely
just having a good time
having a lot of drinks
just that's actually how we know Tyler
is on like a tour like a Travel Group
yeah wow wow this is not the kind of
stuff my girlfriend does I cannot
understand the people that do it so
she's not crazy she went to Mexico on
like a paid tour I'm such a [__]
scumbag they're like I'm like people
normal people don't do this she went on
a trip alone because I'm broke as hell
so that's awesome you guys are all
having a great time that's like Tyler
was killing it in Asia in Asia Tyler's
like a black guy over there
[Laughter]
it's got the biggest dick ever
Tyler what do you like about Asia
I like the uh the pad thai in Thailand
was was great okay okay oh yeah the pad
thai in Tyler drink some cheese okay I
like that I had it out Thai lady boys
no not really no
I guess he doesn't party as hard as I
thought he did
what do you like to do in uh Club
atmosphere are you like the kind of guy
that does a lot of drinking are you more
of a dancer
probably more of a drinker oh yeah he's
got a problem after getting
after having a future
what loose on the Dance Floor I guess
nice I'd love to see that
I haven't had enough drinks yet so okay
uh Sally
he's a man of mystery what do you uh
what do you think Tyler and you would
have in common
that you could do on a date
travel spend money
go um sit on a plane together I suppose
sure sure travel blanket
so uh
what have your ex has been like do you
is there a pattern
um oh my God
yeah they're not with me anymore
they don't know what they missed out on
that's all the pattern I feel you
yeah I feel like uh I would hate to
break up with you because I feel like
you would like tell me exactly what's
wrong with me oh if you break up with a
travel girl you go on Instagram every
[__] day and they're in different
places smiling it's a really it's moving
on from you yeah and it's a different
guy in every picture you're like God
damn these guys are all ripped and uh
from the West Coast
Tyler what Coast are you from
I'm also from California hell yeah and I
live here now how's your body two years
can you show off your six-pack what's
your personal best bench squat uh
overhead press
uh
I lost track I don't know oh wow
you want to wrestle right now
the one number he can't come up with
right now yeah
um but yeah you guys know each other
would you rather go on a date with
someone you don't know
wouldn't that be more fun
I'd rather go on a date that's not on a
stage yeah
Beggars can't be choosers
um so yeah I mean who signed you up your
friend that's recording you probably
signed you up yeah that means she's
coming up next
well you shouldn't sign up your friends
to
go on dates with Tyler
who knows what he's capable of Tyler
what episode what is your love life been
like how's your uh sex life
huh
um
well I've been single obviously
um hopefully not more than two or three
months or you're a [__] loser just
for one month
I mean we could say that I guess but
hell yeah how long how long no no shame
no shame I was kidding I used to be an
incense it's been about a year since my
last like serious relationship that's
not so bad yeah for a man you get to
pursue your dreams career before a girl
comes in and crushes them
so what happened with your last serious
relationship
uh we just didn't really have enough in
common
and you just were like bye she was more
of a girth instead of a life gals or
something
that white ass [__]
um
yeah I don't know we just uh
I just wasn't meant to be I don't know
oh okay it never is trust me
so uh what are you looking for in a girl
um
well someone who likes to travel
somebody likes to
go do activities
go to concerts sporting events what kind
of concerts
just about anything like most I like
mostly rock or alternative but I don't
know for just about anything that's like
such a big uh I don't know it sounds
like those 90s dating videos or like
I've done for rock alternative pretty
much anything sorry
what a very nice you know kind man you
are
um so Sally have you ever dated like a
nice guy before
and how small was his dick
okay
Sally what is your favorite
kind of uh you know sex position no just
kidding don't answer that
um uh Tyler
I had a good question and then I really
want to know your favorite sex position
I forgot it uh uh are you would you
consider yourself that more swag or
class what would you say
[Music]
class all right I figured
a class of 2001.
maybe okay
so yeah that's cool
Sally
any thoughts on the previous question
yet you thinking about it at all
declined to answer that's fair she plead
the fifth okay
um if you had to be on a desert island
and have sex in only one position what
would it be
together
no no don't answer that uh Tyler
question but you're on a volcano you can
answer
can I be on a beach instead that seems a
little bit Yeah you like sand in your
ass no but I don't like lava I don't
know
oh it's anti-lava
you just can't do the rest of my life I
guess I would have to say
I know it's boring but missionary hell
yeah
ew dude that's disgusting if you stay
with the lights off I'm gonna [__]
puke right now foreign
likes to look at people in the eye while
he [__] them while he left Asia because
her eyes are so small
say that yeah if you're listening that
was a Hans joke not a major
uh but Sally do you uh like white guys
wow she is not racist I'm not racist we
got a round of applause she's not racist
everybody yes she's not racist so what
is the last Asian guy you dated since
you're so not racist
my last boyfriend was Asian oh [__]
Round of Applause for dating Asian men
we made it
was a Caucasian oh that's why she
declined the penis question huh that's
why that's why she wouldn't answer it
was from the subcontinent of India
that's cool
um are you Indian as well
yes was it arranged
it was Americanized nice you guys just
met on uh Diwali the Festival of Lights
yeah
the Festival of Lights I feel like I'm
turning balls right now dude
what light was he holding was it like
compatible lights you were like look it
matches I don't know how Diwali works
you guys look like Hanukkah
you guys just have lights and you just
have lights and just sit around and look
at them I don't have any idea what this
is I'm so uncomfortable it's an Indian
holiday apparently for like Stoners and
people on acid just stare at lights uh I
only know the one with the they throw
like colors at each other yeah did you
did you guys do that where you throw
colors at each other
okay
[Music]
yeah
all right that's how post-racial they
are they just they're just all different
colors over there
uh Tyler do you know a lot about Indian
culture have you ever dated an Indian
woman
uh no I have not dated Indian woman well
congratulations we broke your cherry
you've had your first taste of Curry
[Laughter]
how do you feel right now to be part of
one of the largest population groups in
the world you're gonna have little
Indian babies
what are you going to name them
you know wow shy Tyler really avoids any
racial questions he's an expert at not
getting canceled he's a smart man he's a
smart man maybe nowadays if you're that
white you gotta like not get canceled I
don't have a job you can't do [__] to me
yeah
say something that would get you
canceled right now no actually I do have
a job I just was forced to get a job
because of capitalism
well uh Tyler anything that you'd like
to say to uh Sally
not that I can really think of on the
stage wow he is not trying very hard
we can always talk after
that's what we like to hear is that all
the action is going to happen off stage
really helpful in us on a show
Sally anything that you like to say to
uh Tyler maybe about you know future
Hangouts maybe you guys are gonna go
somewhere after this tonight yeah
maybe you want to invite him to Bali go
to Bali yeah let's go let's do it hell
yeah now they're traveling together
another success story give it up for
Tyler and Sally
they went on a date
am I able to ask somebody for a water or
is that me being a rude
Diva Can I have a water yes can we get
Paula water I took Edibles and I watched
Neil Brennan we got Tyler coming up
again is there another Tyler in the
audience
that was Tyler Haskell we just got a
Tyler I think these people are signing
people up willy-nilly
what was uh that woman that signed up
Sally can you come up here just go on a
quick date real quick
yeah
come on up it's the girl that signed up
Sally
karma is a [__]
man I probably look like Fabio on this
fan right here's the name of Sally's or
Miss Frizzle I don't know whoa
it's all right I showed a blade to the
show last week
I went on a date even though I'm taking
it
I broke a young lady's heart you're a
yoga American
um yes please pick up the mic
and we're just gonna interview do a
little pre-interview you yeah the lights
hope the audience see your face welcome
to show business hello oh hello what is
your name Amy Amy what is it with all
these Indians with the whitest names
possible
you guys are like 40 years behind on the
names
Sally and Amy yeah well my name is Hans
so I can't really talk
I got a German name
but uh yeah how do you know Sally she's
my cousin oh of course you guys are all
cousins yeah
so uh what what made you think that uh
Sally would uh want to go on a date
tonight is she
my date we're doing a little
pre-interview so that we get to know you
a little bit a little casting couch
we're doing right
um well it's her birthday so okay just
out at her but yeah no worries she's 30
years old it's almost dead so we're all
here as a group and yeah we're uh we're
we're speed dating signing each other
for things that they're not ready for
yeah you said you're in a relationship
yeah yeah how long have you guys been
together since
since is he here yeah he's right there
oh hey he's recording what a good
boyfriend
he's doing your job
you just get used to it no as a person
in a relationship when I ask you a
question my girlfriends I'm broke I'm a
broke artiste and uh she went on one of
these trips to Mexico alone did she [__]
a guy when she was on that trip you
think so
be honest with me I can tell you yes
she's a sweet angel though
I'm being serious right now
Paul is trying to get out his therapy on
stage okay all right talk to me I think
all right so should I go home and
confront her you're telling me to
confront her sir you're trying to go
home Angry and confront her
all right
thanks for being real
um
um so Sal uh Amy yeah
yeah so uh your boyfriend's right there
you guys have been together for a bit
what do you guys how did you guys meet
um we met on hinge
this is sort of like hinge but in real
life yeah
yeah yeah well let's see if we can
replace cringe
let's see if we can replace your
boyfriend right now with real life hinge
[__] hinge
this show is better we got Aaron hugg
Aaron hugg oh here he is
the late signer up but please don't step
on that table go around
this guy's trying to be funny we always
love a guy that puts an extra effort
wow yes there's stairs over there with
some physical comedy Aaron hug we're
gonna watch a date 90 seconds from Aaron
hugg and Amy starting now okay hey Amy
right hey Aaron how's it going pretty
good pretty good okay yeah so where are
you from
uh Pennsylvania originally outside of
Philadelphia okay I went to school in
Philly you did yeah whereabout temple
temple oh yeah did you carry mace with
you uh or a bodyguard
you never went outside I didn't yeah I
barely went outside honestly it's pretty
dangerous around there yeah yeah I used
to live around there well okay second in
Girard but
yeah what are you doing in Austin that's
a good question
um right now I'm dating uh person that's
got a boyfriend so that's pretty fun
seeing if I can be sick enough to
make the move occur how did you end up
at this comedy thing
here I was here last week yeah oh yeah
who did you date then oh she was uh
was her name Cindy or what's her
friend's name Cindy I was a woman and
and uh we had a good conversation about
you know my sexual habits
yeah okay well how's this stacking up so
far
I guess it's Cindy's date
uh well it didn't go very far after that
but um
I think
she had a daughter here I think it was
her daughter or something so yeah we
kind of talked and I tried to
make it happen with her but okay I'm not
very good at asking being proactive
asking for numbers and stuff so she got
my like website and she's never going to
contact me I said my number's on there
and my time give it up for Aaron hug and
Amy
how did she get your website
um her mom is trying to start a YouTube
thing and I was like I could build your
website you gave it to her and I have a
website where you go is you give people
your website I just start the website
like three weeks ago so I guess that's
my new move websites
what's your website called get
aaronhuglaid.com website woo.com but
aaronhook.com
right there Aaron uh what did you uh
find out on the last time you were on
here didn't we find out that you have a
Twitter and your handle is called Big
Weenie but big big yeah and aren't you
like a porn star or something you like
do only fans with your feet I wish I
wish
I I don't know how to break into that I
mean I I did try to sign up for only
fans this week I don't know if anybody's
ever signed up it's a difficult one okay
thank you Aaron uh Amy what did you what
do you do
[Laughter]
I declined to answer oh I think you have
to answer you have to answer where's Red
band's uh sound effect
client to what
so I'm walking right into this I can't
it's fine fine I'm a podiatrist wow she
works with feet
and this guy loves feet
no no stop bringing her work outside of
work
you ever see people's feet and you're
like damn this guy needs some Podiatry
yes every day that's like that's what I
do like not at your job just out of
public oh out and about no don't
okay I have fluffy what can I do to
alleviate the pain walking around
we'll talk later that'll be a consult
for you oh damn it smart business woman
yeah thanks for free
she looks at human hooves
Aaron what do you like about feet so
much great
I like Good Feet I Don't Like Ugly Feet
let's get that what is a good foot what
does a good foot look like oh
I just know it when I see it it's hard
to I mean they have to be in line
like in a good line sloping from Big to
small you sound like a serial killer
right now
are you collecting feet I've seen a lot
more footless women around Austin I
think I found her
I mean the worst things that second long
toe bigger than the big toe I can't I
can't hang you're never a big second
never date someone like that this
conversation what happened to you when
you were a child because this
[Laughter]
did someone step on you
dropped
dropped by a foot dropped but that was
because I bit my mom's neck
God damn this guy's got a lot of issues
Amy how safe do you feel right now
really questioning our choices it's all
good if he comes at you I'll I'll kick
him and he'll get distracted by a
beautiful feet
so what's the weirdest
what's the weirdest date besides this
one that you've been on
yeah besides this one oh besides this
one the weirdest date I've ever been on
our first date wasn't that weird on
hinge yeah yeah let's talk about that
neat stories to be honest like how did
so who messaged did we already say who
messaged you and what they said like
what was the openers here because you
gotta teach that's something you can
teach people guys terrible openers women
it doesn't matter you know
guys are just there for the for it you
know what I mean
I got kicked off of hinge I didn't ask
you anything they want to tell me it was
I moved here four months ago five months
ago and I was messaging a lot of people
to try to hang out because I don't know
anybody yeah and one of the policies is
you have to be in it for love and I
think they were like this guy just wants
to get laid
because he's messaging everybody he's a
I think they kick me off he's a
go-getter that is not why your case
you're off I promise I've messaged
plenty of people around single and I was
very like I think
I think it's trying to get laid on hand
they did not kick me off
they probably let me smell your feet
[Laughter]
so how did you guys meet who said what
to who first do you remember
don't remember exactly I mean he he
messaged me first but then it was a big
lapse of time before we actually like
met up in person
um you let him cook yeah you're like
stew for a bit I'm gonna go [__] other
people did they say how long they've
been dating what uh
April yeah this is April it's almost a
year
oh exciting
who gave who coronavirus first
uh do we do we have it together
no separately
yeah wow you guys are cheating on each
other
coughing on someone that's not your
boyfriend
oh [__] yeah well let's talk to Lionel
Messi right now after he lost the World
Cup
that's what you look like oh no Messiah
yeah that's a good one you guys didn't
like it I loved it you're making me feel
good after I've been playing a lot of
FIFA
I'm sorry no that's all right
uh uh so what is your favorite thing to
do on a date
[Music]
I'm in soccer whenever I answer the
question the first date foot action
I mean
have fun
number one so you're trying to meet
women have you considered going to
random podiatrist office saying have
problems with your feet and then getting
them to check them out and sort of like
not her office obviously don't talk to
her ever again and we might be liable
yeah
well I don't know
I'm not gonna illegally I'm not gonna be
allowed to yes but you know just go in
just be like a stub my toe also is your
second toe bigger than your first toe
what's going on with that you ever
consider doing that I broke a toe once
oh yeah yeah how's that in a sexual
accident I was wasted no it was I was 22
years old and I was wild and drunk
sticking your toe where it didn't belong
something like that yeah he's a bandit I
never went to the podiatrist I didn't
have insurance I just so what happened
with your toes five months well now it's
a little crooked what happened to make
it crooked
what happened I jumped off a balcony oh
and the whitest answer you could have
given
that wasn't anything too bad really some
jackass [__] you jumped off a balcony
onto the first floor onto the parking
lot you know oh there's nothing better
to land on than a parking lot yeah nice
and hard
so you just landed tow first
I landed right on that one toe
apparently because the rest of the foot
was okay your Achilles toe I don't know
how the middle like there's I think it
was the middle toe it just broke all the
other ones kept it or all the other ones
did their own thing and that one just
said here I'm coming I'm taking all the
pain for the team what would you
diagnose him with he has Achilles toe
was that what you say yeah he has an
invincible toe can I ask her I mean do a
lot of people break the like the middle
toe just the one toe yeah yeah wow a lot
of people break toes just one yeah but
it was the most commonly bro the most
commonly broken toe you're familiar with
out of the five uh the five Piggly
wigglies which one is broken the most
oh that makes sense yeah I still got one
all the time
yeah just a medical advice podcast now
I think I should get another chance I'm
Up Against All Odds here beautiful taken
okay
um Doctor Amy so yeah if you had to say
and uh
you know like qualify Aaron as one of
the toes what toe would you say he is
well since we're talking about the
middle toes so much
the middle toe
the second one that's the isn't that the
second toe the middle toe is the third
toe the middle toes the middle toe
Oh you mean like the third toe yeah I
don't know what you meant I meant just
anything you meant the second toe okay
yeah the second toe okay I kind of feel
like you just stole my answer the
ringtone
so that's the toe you think he's you
think he's long but not girthy
a real Tyler situation
he stands out Above the Rest he might
not have the weight but he's very tall
in personality he's got a unique
personality
fighting
ask questions as a podiatrist I don't
get these kinds of questions in my work
Aaron hug if he had to qualify Amy as
one of the toes which toe do you think
Amy would be
um
the pink the pinky I don't know she's
cute she's broken okay she's
she's broken she's shy and she's cute I
gotcha don't land on her in a parking
lot
it's not parking lot friendly
well thank you guys for going on a date
with each other
for the dates
not an easy thing don't sign your
friends up
that's what you get you get towed we
learned a little lesson we're gonna find
out someone with a fetish and stick you
with him
we got Noor a man
nor newer
do you have four letters in your name
and the first one is an n
woman
well come on up [__]
[Music]
she doesn't know what gender she is is
this another
is this another friendly sign up
well you know what that means
Noor welcome to the show
[Applause]
which cousin are you
let's get the mic working
there we go awesome Sally's sister yeah
and
it's Amy's cousin wow this is this is
just like we're just trying to get this
one family to like
have a lot of children
huh
nope not twins
apart
this guy's trying to fulfill a fantasy
um yeah I'd love uh love a good uh a
clan you know we've had your whole
all your all your females up here
um what is like something that binds you
guys together something about your
family do you guys have like a lot of
cousins
no it's actually just
it's just us three
yeah what a coincidence
that we got all of you guys up here
tonight yeah
are you single I am nice
finally
we had someone that wasn't single wait
so you said sister right I'm sorry I'm
gonna add a pulse right I'm the first
I'm Sally's sister okay and older
younger I'm younger younger okay what's
the most annoying thing about Sally
okay
spill the tea girl
um she makes jokes that are not funny
at all she'd be perfect for this show
what kind of jokes like Dad jokes like
puns and [__] that I just can't get
behind yeah yikes
so she's not punny no
well you know when it's your sibling
that tries to make a joke and you're
like
yeah it would be funny of someone else I
love my siblings I laugh hard at all
their jokes
what a what a mensch
well I have two brothers so that's
probably why yeah the men are actually
funny yeah uh that's one thing I won't
argue oh
you're the only one that doesn't have
the most whitest oldest name ever
what is uh what does the name Noor come
from or signify it's
it's like word it means light
nice it's just cool yeah
honestly that's really cool my name is
Paul
what's up what does that mean I don't
know dude these I got called a [__] in
high school a lot
I think that's more to do with your body
type
um very hurtful what is your man what is
your ideal Man sound like tall giving
she's looking for a basketball player
with a charity
Manchester Damian Lillard perhaps
Kim Kardashian Khloe Kardashian is your
role model
just want to [__] what's that guy I was
gonna say Kardashian Vibes earlier but
loyal okay looking for a dog Golden
Retriever perhaps
a giving dog dogs are giving dogs aren't
very tall
uh but yeah I think that we have plenty
of suitors in here that fit that
description
let's get one up here
who signed up in the correct bucket
hopefully Tyler again how many times you
guys sign up Tyler
you guys are [__] with Tyler
oh man this is like the heroin they
tried to ring it
just because he looks like a giant nerd
doesn't mean he needs extra help to get
laid
I'm just kidding Josh
here he comes Josh
he says sorry I'm not tall he's a short
King he sure can
he's very giving and loyal
I hope
give it up for Josh and Noor going on a
date for 90 seconds
it starts we're just going okay hi nice
to meet you nice to meet you too where
are you from I am from New Haven
Connecticut I've been awesome for about
three and a half years yeah oh wow nice
I'm from Sacramento California you live
in Sacramento I do are you like a Kings
fan uh I don't watch basketball but on
the weekends I'm a Kings fan oh
no
is it on now yes it is okay maybe I just
wasn't talking into it I'll be closer uh
what'd you say
um I don't watch basketball but okay if
there's alcohol involved I'm a Kings fan
for sure okay well that's fun
do you like Sacramento I've heard mix I
have a love hate relationship I love the
city but I don't like the people there
wow everyone's really mean that everyone
in Austin is so nice how do you like a
city when you don't like the people
that's like there's a lot of fun bars
and food and stuff but the people make
it not enjoyable it's like really good
bars but the people are terrible yeah
the bars yeah you're doing a bar when
you don't like the people there
[Music]
it's a good question I usually go home
okay yeah reasonable yeah it sounds
reasonable what do you do
uh I am in School of Social Work and I'm
in I work in Learning and Development
nice so I'm in school and working at the
same time yeah cool yeah how about you
I'm an urban planner really yeah wow
that's so cool actually yeah I uh love
cities
thought about going to school for urban
planning oh really interesting it's very
interesting yeah and time give it up for
the urban planner and the
School social worker guy I feel like I
was watching an episode of Laguna Beach
that was a shout out for the old people
on the ground Laguna Beach
California
real California bars yeah like what's
the girl's name Elsie or whatever just
like yeah yeah it's cool
really
yeah wow she's a ocog
anyways
[Music]
Let's uh not have any feedback maybe
um Josh
you are not tall you said that on your
way up here I'm not no you didn't have
to say it but you said it really point
guard
are you a fan of
I'm a Knicks fan he's the next fan oh
I'm sorry he's not tall but he can boss
around other tall people if he can
control the tolls you're tall why do you
need to be tall just have them grab [__]
for you
um
so yeah you work at as a school social
worker you know maybe you're so giving
that it makes up for your height how
much does he have to give to make up for
the height
okay Noor is uh
a highest when you're doing school
social work do you get mistaken as one
of the children ever
yeah
oh me from behind you're like you know
short guy that's a short joke
what do you do with children
I I don't work with children I'm in
school for social work
you are a child yeah not really hit but
are you like an undergraduate or a
graduate no I'm a grad student okay yeah
nice so I work I work full time and I go
to school part-time do you want to bump
and grind on each other to the music
that's playing right now from outside
would that be the second date
it's like that was not actually a
suggestion I was trying to get a joke to
address the
Bassy music that's going in the walls
right now it's happening I'm not my not
my animals okay
so Noor uh what do you like to do in
Austin
ours have been a lot of fun we went out
to 36. the best thing about bars in
Austin there's no Sacramento people in
them yeah
unless you're in there
there was them but
it's fine
Sacramento also a landlocked capital of
a major State you're just going from
Capital to Capital
[__] up a storm
have you been uh seeing a lot of people
in Austin or have you been mostly
keeping to yourself I've been keeping to
myself and my crew
oh you just [__] inside your crew no
that's not true I'm related to all of
them so no okay
uh Josh what is your preferred uh area
to Prey Upon sexually
like uh differently
yeah I got nothing for you on that one
where do you go if you want if you're
like I need to get my dick wet like
where do you go I actually have a
partner
so you go inside your partner yeah where
is she at usually uh they use they don't
pronouns they actually were gonna come
here but they bailed on me they didn't
want to come so you came alone yeah I
did oh yeah yeah I'm sorry I got a lot
of stuff alone though I kind of hang out
with us maybe today yeah maybe they
could have identified as a good partner
and come with you
thank you I appreciate that yeah very
nice of you so now you're in this friend
group
technically you're a cousin of Noor now
so
I can't [__]
what do you guys like to do as like your
giant Posse you guys go challenge people
with the you know soccer games or we we
drink
we've been eating a lot eating and
drinking yeah wow
so uh would you be down for that Josh
would you be down to eat and drink I I
do like eating and drinking yeah hell
yeah yeah if your partner's still busy
for the rest of the night you guys you
can totally come out with us that's so
nice of you yeah wow that's very I hope
you all feel okay about that no the
morning yeah
this group is really holding this show
together very suicide
exception I had friends dude it seems
fun
yeah
second episode of Indian friends
[Laughter]
so uh if you could teach Josh anything
about your Indian culture what would it
be
when we get married
sisters and girlfriends of the Bride oh
[__] you no they all take money from the
groom like thousands of dollars to like
as like a bribe to give her away to him
so we make money off of every time like
a sister or girlfriend gets married we
make money off of it
sounds like my haha
sounds like my last trip to the brothel
I got fleeced well that's good you know
some trickle-down economics
Josh are you ready to make this kind of
commitment I mean that's good that's a
good thing to know for sure
[Laughter]
um what ethnicity is your partner uh my
partner is white they are sort of Irish
Scottish background and I'm Jewish oh I
love the Jews oh thank you thank you she
loves the juice I wonder why after
saying we take money from the groom
she's attracted to your bank account
do you have a lot of money to give
plead the fifth on that
smart like a Jew
you don't want to waste all your money
on your first wife
save it up
um that's cool so have you ever been
close to getting married have you ever
been engaged no I'm 22. okay now this
feels like a crime not a child bride
yeah
Josh uh how old are you I'm 33. wow
okay don't let Twitter know about this
dude the FBI has been alerted
um that's cool so you guys have an 11
year age difference yeah
yeah what would you tell Noor about 911
for him
are you not alive I was
yeah nine months old just watching the
world change
balance for 9 11 of course
she'll never know the pain that we have
to go through to invade Iraq for no
reason
Noor how's uh have you ever been back to
India yeah I went this year for the
first time after 15 years
March last year so you went as a kid 15
years ago it was five last time we went
and then we went last year nice how have
things changed in those 15 years it's
much more modern
and a little less dirty oh nice yeah
what did she say I don't hear dirty I
don't know okay other words but thrown a
lot all those men lost a lot of girth on
their dick in 15 years
as a five-year-old
now
hey reset let's say you do back on that
let me get on that one a lot less dirty
that's good yeah
whenever I picture India there's a lot
of dirt in the mix
somebody loved that over there
that's a British guy that's laughing
about colonialism
so how did you like Gandhi
you hate him oh he actually really
resociated black people
religious minorities and he was like
raping miners so okay well anyone can
knit did he ever try stand-up comedy it
sounds like you get far in that
yeah he sounds like Bill Cosby yeah
probably really funny
guy real crystalline over here dude
are you uh one of the religious
minorities in India
yes oh nice hello
what's uh which one are you I'm
sorry
oh nice
yeah just play it back it's recorded on
YouTube the guy looks like he's kicked
out of the UFC wants an RFP right now
the guy that looks like he hates
minorities
uh nope she hates Gandhi anyways uh Josh
what are your thoughts what are some uh
like famous people that everyone loves
that you hate
wow I'm still reflecting on that here
seek I think that's so interesting I the
little I know about
Sikhism is really inspiring I think so
be curious to hear more about that um
he's just having a weird religion
so he's respecting yours a celebrity I
hate that other people love her a world
figure
uh benevolent person like what are you
what are your thoughts on Mother Teresa
I I honestly don't have any I don't know
much about her
yeah
what do you think about
Benjamin not Netanyahu
I think he's really terrible he's the
one oh [__] yeah I mean
beef started that's a pretty common
sentiment I don't know yeah yeah very
different Josh uh so you are actually
you know respect Sikhism or Sikhism I do
because it's so sick
uh what is what do you know about
Sikhism that maybe would impress Noor
that like oh this guy actually is well
traveled and knows the world
well I'm not sure because I could be
totally misremembering but my memory of
it is that it's very oriented around
peace and maybe there's like a
vegetarian component to it
um so those are the things that I
remember he's a cheap date he doesn't
want to pay for your steak dinner
Willy won at Franklin's yesterday but
you're absolutely
you're like a lapse to seek I yeah I
don't really believe in it anymore but
that's how I was raised yeah yeah you
just hate Gandhi
um
Josh anything that you could uh teach
Noor about Judaism
um
this guy is uh is alerting Alex Jones
right now to the latest this is a racism
we can do now he's got a Shepherd fairy
shirt on he's not an Alex Jones
oh boy yeah
yeah you're racist
does that trigger you are you triggered
right now
oh my God you're at a comedy show sir
please don't be a snowflake
be a little tougher you're gonna get
called names
my Dad's here everybody dude
thank you for coming sir
yeah right we're learning something new
every day in fairness when I play the
video game civilization civilization six
I choose Gandhi as my character every
time she got that one I knew there was a
gamer in the audience
anyways do you want to teach uh us about
Judaism please oh wow what do you want
to know I still like Gandhi's music you
know even if he is canceled
on hell and it seems to like not be uh
to me it seems like he's not really in
his right mind anymore so I think that's
that and also dangerous yeah
very empathetic way to say that good job
thanks well we all have our opinions you
know he is the greatest rapper of all
time so
he really doesn't care about what you
think about him
well um you guys seem like a great
couple you know you guys seem like you
guys would you know get along and you
know just chill it'd be a very chill
relationship
yeah that's good [__] missionary style
licking each other in the eye
anyways
nor what is your favorite thing about
Jewish men
the giving
giving what like they're always
hilarious
they're the funniest people ever sorry
yeah Josh say do something funny right
now no it doesn't work that way
not a stand-up comedian over here
you're doing great everyone's doing
great
I just want to let everyone know all the
guests they're doing great it's been fun
yeah you're doing awesome oh thanks so
much well again
they went on a date thank you
walk into a bar
now it's time for a segment of the show
called better Noah gay
we've got one in here and we're gonna
exploit them you learn about the game
Gabriella
lgbtqia
Gabriella Ella here she comes
how great would be if they pick that
guy's name out of me I'll beat you
what if that guy he was the one that put
his name yeah
the most ugliest gay guy ever
Gabriella welcome to the show thank you
so much for signing up
[Applause]
[Music]
the last guy that tried to talk [__] in
the show that's what happened I hit him
over there with it then the mic is
dented everybody he was offended
um yes the mic is a little busted
struggling with this I get it now
she empathizes with your pain
ooh you're a copy editor what is a copy
editor what is that
why write jokes at my job too some you
know so I write jokes and I make sure
everything's grammatically correct oh
[__] like content like or uh trying like
the blur the blurb underneath something
something we'll be looking at content is
more informative because he's supposed
to sell you so copy is like everything
you'd read in an advertisement or like
here in a promo video I don't know this
is really boring guys if you had to if
you had to give a copy for this show in
two or three words what would it be
absolute
[Laughter]
absolute dumpster fires you said yeah
she's a writer she doesn't really
project as much but uh yeah I think that
Mike will pick it up if you just oh I'm
not going to the top of it yes
um so what is your dating life like so
far
nothing's going I thought I was gonna
fall in love tonight I was so ready well
there's still a chance well I'm I'm
bisexual so it can be a man okay anyone
literally anyone can come up here right
now
do you have a pulse
how uh do we you're living in Austin
have you lived here for a while I used
to live
from UT and
okay so I'm just here
because San Marcos is really boring and
before College where did you live
okay
cool
nice yeah are you uh what are you
racially are you I'm Puerto Rican oh
wow yeah I didn't expect that
really
all the way from Puerto Rico no
unfortunately my parents
um made the first mistake of of birthing
me here in the states I could have had a
really cool origin story yeah like I was
born in a like without running water
well
our paper towels according to that last
thing wasn't that where the it was an
old reference oh yeah yeah all right you
read the news sir well we have a Puerto
Rican right here uh
yeah
this is for charity by the way I'm being
auctioned off I come with a bag yes
we're auctioning off lesbians tonight
I mean bisexuals
so if you had to choose which bucket
should we draw from this straight man or
straight woman bucket what's up that we
can grow the crowd shoes as well is
there I don't want to take your shirt
yeah the crowd what does the crowd think
woman woman I heard Woman twice everyone
wants to see a woman no one wants to see
a man again
men are the worst
okay here we go we're gonna
get a woman
[Applause]
Sophie is not coming up
homophobe
I gotta get another
Tara
going on a date
with Gabriella
super fun never seen this before in real
life so a date
so excited okay ready go
no
struggle now it's on Amazing hi I like
your hair oh well I like your hair too
everything's big in Texas with your hair
that's so teased I like your shirt I
like your pants and I don't know what
else to say because you're not a lesbian
so I don't want to hit on you don't know
that
why are you assuming
hi hi
just kidding
um how are you how are you doing tonight
good yeah is your night just starting or
middle uh well the weekend's been long
we've partied all night long so we're
we're just keep we're just keeping it
going trucking on yeah okay love that
love to see it what'd you do before this
uh we went to Franklin's actually we
waited in line all day
yeah did everybody wait way way too much
meat okay okay I'm here for it yeah I
like me have you been to Franklin's I
haven't I haven't lived a life
unfortunately what
um okay so Franklin's Trucking on what's
what's going to happen after this I
don't know you tell me
I'm sitting back there
buy me a coffee you don't go on dates
then I'm on a date right now calling me
out fair enough yeah she's she's like
this isn't a date
um no uh do I go on dates um not really
not really right now no no have you been
on dating apps
I am on a dating app I recently joined
uh Bumble Libby one
um guys it's insane there are so many
dudes on Bumble like I have not are you
always looking for dudes no I'm I'm on
both but it's like a thousand [__]
dudes I'm like where are these guys
coming from bro like and time give it up
for Gabriella and her dates
[Applause]
wow so many dudes yeah I don't know
exhausted
like dicks are valueless they really are
it's fine you can say it
yeah yeah you uh ate at Franklin's today
I did and now you are not eating meat on
this date because there's no penis on
stage that you're dating you know uh
well there's some skirt steak
whoa
Amy sure everybody nice
I like my day she's really fun oh thank
you I think we all love your date right
now
uh
we're all enjoying this date who is uh
the person that you came here with the
luckiest guy in the world today Josh
hello Josh you're about to have a
threesome without having to put in any
effort
you you are you just stumble into this
what a lucky guy so what is like your
favorite thing to do uh uh with your
significant other over there oh we go to
a lot of comedy shows we go to a ton of
coffee you look like one of your fans
do an improv while you're in bed
together just like dirty talking
no I wish I mean maybe we can start that
as a tradition I'm a tree and I'm
[__] you
[Laughter]
that's cool I love a good improv artist
uh Gabriella what what kind of uh art
form are you into do you have any
hobbies
um
Hobbies I
getting into gardening but I feel like
everyone is now because everyone's
really scared because they're gonna run
out of food supply yeah it's called
survival at this point yeah I'm like
looking into prepping stuff I've never
done that it's really weird I was making
a joke about it but she's
seriously I'm like really anyway
um I've never heard of scared gardening
but oh well it's like I'm like crying
planting Kale like
vitamin A
um anyway no gardening I like gardening
I like
um reading
but I do like to read reading yeah what
kind of what was the last book you read
so the last book I read so okay so I
write copyright so a lot of copy or most
of copy is
trying to figure out what the person on
the other side of the screen is thinking
and feeling and how they make decisions
so the last book I read is basically
about how people make decisions the
cognitive shortcuts just brainy [__] I
think I know what he's thinking right
now I think he's thinking I would like
to have a threesome with these two women
oh this guy's here this guy's
introduction
Josh
um have you ever had a threesome before
[Laughter]
tattoos goatee That's a classic
wow what a nice guy uh what was your
name again
Tara Tara yeah so what uh what kind of
experience do you like to set out during
a threesome for Josh what what is he
into
well
he said the butt stuff
oh my God
are we talking tongue finger what are we
talking here
oh Jesus
tongue and finger and dick
not yet okay he's homophobic stop trying
to get another threesome okay yeah why
can't I join
Tara so uh have you ever been on a date
with a woman before
wow how does it how does it differ from
men is it like better well we always
compliment each other a whole lot more I
think when you're on a date with a girl
yeah men are really bad at complimenting
women they're just like love your tits
nice ass
what's like a way that women complement
each other that men don't
question for both of you your
personality yeah yeah like you're so
smart I like who you are like that was
so smart of you to say that was so funny
yeah right yeah like that was really a
great answer
you're really smart for saying that
women say that to me all the time when
I'm on days of them
that's because they're trying to get out
of your van
oh you're so
sweet
[Laughter]
anyways enough man talk
let's let the women take over
what do you women like to do what is
your favorite womanly thing WNBA
witchcraft uh I have no idea what women
are like
I don't even know a woman right now
I like to go to the spa ooh rest and
relaxation yeah
and do you get like a sort of treatment
do they like do a pedicure or is it just
like a
body wraps facials that's nice yeah
facials right yes that's where you come
in
[Laughter]
Gabriella what is something that uh you
enjoy
um flexing my female privilege
my favorite woman
flexing our ovaries in front of men oh
yeah oh you know it gets you so far are
we talking kegels that we're talking
[Laughter]
I do them too it's not just females
all right guys
we all like butt stuff who doesn't like
butt stuff according to the pro Buster
crowd I love it
Gabriella anything uh crazy that
happened recently in your dating life
I met Tara
um she called you crazy she's a charmer
Wild
like just never know who you're gonna
meet you know no not I'm serious I
haven't been dating I don't know I don't
want to I haven't been dating just been
writing copy all day just just slaving
away on their own hinge just writing
yourself the best taglines my profile is
really funny I think I believe that it's
funny I'm a very funny person clever
yeah yeah is there like a line from your
hinge that you can tell us right now
yeah so one of the prompts is I'm a real
nerd about something and I said I'm a
real nerd about searching through
Twitter for red flags to find new
personality traits so that was one of
them well luckily on this show the red
flags just present themselves
and then they sit in the crowd after the
interview
so that's cool
[Music]
thank you
what is like uh something that you would
like to do with Tara for your second
date
Spa should we go to the spa I think so
should we go to a naked spot
whoa
the girls never ask me that
Tara I'm so nervous we're on stage ask
me later have you ever been to a naked
spot no they're amazing really yeah okay
describe them to us
picture this okay I'm picturing it
you go into a locker room you get
undressed you put your robe on but you
go out and there's tons of different
pools and different uh temperatures you
can go hang out and and then lining the
pool there are tables and women are
being aggressively scrubbed by angry
Asian women
it's amazing I'm here for that or the
pull of your skin comes off are the
pools like coffee pools milk you know
what I mean like no no no no no okay
water just different degrees of water
okay yeah okay yeah that sounds pleasant
it's awesome
I don't feel appropriate going I feel
like no it feels inappropriate for me
it's like of a man Wang I'm like what
the [__] are you doing here yeah we all
have the same Parts just the body I know
you're right yeah you're right I should
go you know what yeah you're right you
changed my mind oh yeah you changed my
mind yeah Gabriella is going to a naked
whatever
that's awesome Asian woman's Spa take a
couple pictures for us send them over to
other people comedy
um but that's cool so have you been to
this spot before is it in Dallas
no I actually live in uh Washington uh
state Washington State yep oh BMW
that's where all the naked Asian women
are scrubbing white women yeah they're
they're
the Asian orange or napalm
that's cool so there's a lot of uh naked
spas in Washington if you ever want to
go there
I would go to Washington what do you
recommend doing in Washington besides
being naked at a spa oh you got to do
Pike Place Market okay
um
oh that's in Seattle right okay I've
been actually one I've been to Seattle I
forgot myself
that's how bad of a city it is you
forget you were there before
it was rainy uh it was raining it was so
cloudy if you were to write copy for
Seattle it'd just be rainy and
forgettable
and some fish
[Laughter]
well I certainly won't be forgetting
Seattle from now on home of naked women
running around and Pike Place don't know
and Pike Place not as exciting
um
so yeah you guys are great you're doing
great anything that you like to say to
Gabriella Tara
thank you yeah it's been fun Gabriella
is there something that you would like
to uh maybe suggest to Tara maybe like
you know like in the future do you have
any like anything in the future that
might happen to her like just any sense
or feelings right so I don't have any
red flags do I I don't I don't know
what are you asking me green flags yeah
oh
no sir YouTube that's for that's what I
was thinking not what I was saying yeah
well
anything like anything that you like to
say to Josh maybe to
steal his woman
done
no I'm just kidding
um no I don't know I don't know dude you
should compliment Josh be like hey good
job dude
it's he didn't make her she did it oh
[__] feminism against myself hell yeah
dude oh did you just point out your tits
and she pointed out her tits and she
said she made them herself
great job uh you did an amazing job on
this
uh
anyways I really don't know what to say
to women I wish I was a man here I could
just brow out with
sorry dude that's my fault
all these women are making me look like
a sexual predator yeah totally yeah it's
their fault yeah
well uh
Tara do you want to go on a date with a
man
sure okay
it's my turn
no just kidding thank you so much man
thank you Gabriella so much
thanks for everybody who comes up here
we got plural
parowelu p-o-r-a-u-l
okay we got Chase
The Thrill of the chase
coming on up
that's not Chase
we got Shadow oh here he comes it's Chad
oh
[Applause]
foreign
Shadow with the strut he takes his time
dragging that big old dick onto the
stage Shadow and Tara
hi
nice to meet you
it's not on
wait for it
hold there it is why do they keep on
turning it off is it just for to [__]
with everybody else that's fun
all right so Tara I'm Chad how you doing
I'm good how are you nice to meet you
yeah so you're this you're just visiting
I am just visiting from Washington State
very cool yeah do you live around here I
I do live around here I live North uh
North Austin now okay yeah how long have
you lived here uh since August so but
it's been it's been a fun experience
it's a little bit colder than what I'm
used to I came from Arizona oh so I know
it's kind of what you're used to up in
Washington it's frigid yeah it's warmer
here now yeah yeah I was freezing yeah
yeah that's cool uh no I uh I know so I
know you're here with a dude uh just I
am married uh yeah but we're in an open
relationship happily uh no no no no
that's over a relationship you know so
yeah it you know we're taking turns you
know you're taking turns being unhappy
so yeah that that does work you know
sometimes she's unhappy sometimes it's
me but all right yeah that's fair yeah
yeah yeah balance it out yeah so how
long have you guys been you guys been
together uh three years oh well so yeah
getting into the unhappy stages yet or
still happy no I still like it oh yeah
yeah that's cool yeah wait's that
10-year Mark that 10-year Mark is where
it comes in now I've been married 23
[__] years really yeah yeah yeah
that's awesome yeah yeah so you're due
for a new girl yeah super on the same
page and time give it up for the soon to
be divorced Chad oh
and home wrecker Tara winner cup was to
go that long and then they become like
an open relationship it's like
refinancing your mortgage before you
before close the house but the interest
rate's always higher yeah yeah yeah it's
never a good idea but you're like well
we gotta try to save the house but a
great APR you have on your current wife
yeah it's a it's a uh a revolving line
of credit it just keeps on coming back
nice yeah that's a that's a great way to
describe herpes yeah yeah that's true
that happened after the relationship
open the relationship I'm kidding I'm
kidding that was bad no all the faces no
no no words just faces
no words just faces
I don't I don't have herpes okay no one
asked uh I can prove it I don't know a
very clean clean bill of Hell shadow
uh Tara what is your favorite thing
about dating men
favorite thing about dating men
wow I mean besides that dude
took the words right out of my mouth
besides Josh is thick I mean sorry Josh
um
oh I like I like being around men
because it makes me feel safe yeah yeah
there's at least one guy is not gonna
kill you right away
Shadow can you make women feel safe I do
I uh I make it feel safe
in a very very secure room that was a
loaded question where they can't get out
what is your favorite move to make women
feel safe
um it's a you know when you open the
door for him it goes a long way you know
it's just just that little extra step of
because they know they can get out of
the room yeah yeah well you probably
open the door they're happy you know
they're just happy to see somebody yeah
that's why I always tap that handicap
button yeah
I thought open it for them
I'm not handicapped
don't say it say it sorry and again
people have the best doors and toilets
and parking spots hotel rooms too oh
what are you doing in handicap hotel
rooms I I got booked in one and they
have the shower is the floor you just
walk right into it the head comes off
like if for a tall guy it's really great
to have a handicap and the porn the porn
is really fun handicapped part yeah yeah
oh my God please don't [__] over your
chances Shadow you're still on a date
sorry sorry
notice the red tablecloth this is not
the time to be talking about handicapped
porn
but what kind of handicap horn do you
watch
you know anything with the amputee is
fine I think yeah amputees
oh my God hey you the foot guy had to
get together dude take it home with you
you two should start dating take it home
with you that's horrible Tara do you uh
what do you think about this handicap
porn thing is that like a red flag it's
it's like
uh
when Terry come up here is like I'm just
I'm just severe I'm down with everything
I'm just like I'm actually gonna move
back home
[Laughter]
I floats your boat stop by boat
they really can't swim that well so you
have to float the boat
you gotta float the boats he says
Shadow what's your uh what's what's the
what's the best way to ease people in
into your porn habits do you just like
tell them right away usually when they
wake up and you're just watching it
that's like the best way but oh yeah
this is already on that's not the best
way
and you probably should have it on a
record that that's your way legally no
that's really not the best way I I uh I
think once you get into the handicap
hotel room they're kind of just already
open for that well you just got to show
them like this is my experiment there's
a bunch of my girlfriends in wheelchairs
and stuff so they know
the wheelchair is just optional too you
know the the if they like to uh
you know be helped it's not it's it's
not really where it's at you want you
want somebody who's independent jump out
of the chair and jump on you type of
person you know yeah you don't want
someone that's too handicapped yeah and
not somebody who wants to be helped you
want you want them to do it for
themselves too you know we need to
install a ramp on the stage
yeah for shadow yeah I'm I'm I'm I'm a
I'm a uh [__] encourager I don't know
[__] is encouraging handicapped people
uh me and my girlfriend recently brought
porn in a lot during sexual activities
you know uh and then she'll get upset
that I'm staring at the point a little
bit too long it's like then but it's on
you know I mean like yeah it's like that
like so I have to divide my attempt you
know yeah it's like at a bar when you're
watching sports yeah it's just
distracting yeah it's like if it's on
it's on you know I can watch it but you
don't play soccer and watch soccer
oh he got you there yeah he's on your
girlfriend's side this is careful about
talking about soccer with his foot guy
on the car I was gonna get a boner no
podiatrist it's like don't play soccer
Tara are you ever into some weird or
something freaky like Shadow isn't a
handicapped porn is there something that
might not be normal that you're into
okay
I mean uh what about Josh
that dude's shorts say freak
you don't come in wearing tight short
shorts like that without without having
some fun he's hitting on Josh I noticed
when he came in Josh we wanted to cut
off one of your limbs to have sex with
us
all right oh just an improv Master he
will give up an arm or a leg
so uh anyways
are you uh so you signed up for this
bucket right you're like you knew that
you were gonna go on a date is Josh okay
with that is it like yeah you're looking
for a third yeah
what is what are the pros and cons of
Gabriella and Shadow right now who's
who's in the lead
Gabriella oh I'm not gonna lie
so can the third be your second place
well five can go out and hang out you
know at least you're in the running she
wouldn't even consider me they're both
open to a third that's either a guy or
or a gal it's not
or them yeah oh that's you're only
looking for gal I want to point out she
did put her thing in the straight female
okay yeah down with the female that's
that's kind of [__] up on me my part
that's how bad I'm doing is that she
signed up to date a dude and is walking
out with a chick
well yeah that's that's my bad
yeah
yeah she's uh you know yeah I did
terrible batting out of your league or
whatever that's an Uber rating of zero
anyways uh Tara what is the uh something
that you look for uh during a date
uh somebody who's funny somebody who's
confident
Shadow can you say something funny and
confident I was confident until she said
somebody was funny [__] I thought I was
doing all right
no I don't know
aren't funny knock knock
who's there China what's up baby
see nope
well better luck next time Shadow all
right fine get somebody else up here
um well anything you want to say to
chatto may be some advice for the next
date he's on
yeah that came up naturally yeah yeah I
didn't mean to do don't be natural
don't be mean
don't be natural that is the dating
advice that Tara has given us all right
I'll take that home with me
even if it comes up naturally be
unnaturally avoiding handicapped porn
just say you watch normal normal porn I
don't don't even say you watch porn at
all yeah I should have stopped at the
handicap shower
yeah sorry tell me like this one was
really nice I have to apologize for
things that you like well I mean I'm
just like the shower the porn was on I
think it was from the previous guest
okay yeah the shower was nice though
properly themed porn for the handicap
hotel room yeah
Paul anything you want to say to chatto
and Tara
I don't think it's gonna work out
between you two oh man but and if you
want to introduce women to MPD porn
consider maybe showing porn with a girl
with a limp and then you know just ease
him into it that is true hey but me and
my wife never went on separate vacations
in 23 years just so you know
okay that was the question well uh we're
still monogamous not [__] other
people yeah you are still monogamous
we seem pretty happy
Paul's so I'm going on vacation with
your girl next year I think yeah all
right what do you pay for it dude
whatever I don't give a [__] I have to
pay for it I got stuff to do here dude
yeah give it up for a chat
[Applause]
that was the show what a wonderful
series of dates that we've seen
they were all great everyone was good
it's hard to beat his first Super Shadow
[__] no I'm just kidding he's great
everyone was amazing thank you so much
for coming out give it up for Paul
Cypher as he is online at the real Paul
ciphers
thank you so much good night
[Applause]